how many times have you been hired by a
hollywood studio or producer where they
did not require you to outline for
writing a script
um
that's sort of tricky because i would
never not outline so therefore whether
they required or not i was going to do
it the interesting thing is whether or
not they understood how much work an
outline is
because the truth is very often
in order to figure out the solutions to
a story to make the choices of a story
because that's really what figuring out
the solutions is is saying it's going to
be a story about this it's going to be a
story where this is the central action
that's the outlining process
and that's very very difficult that can
take as harder work than writing the
script
and so everyone is always asking you to
essentially do that work before they
decide whether they're going to hire you
although
things have changed a little bit but
truthfully most people assume that an
outline
is very short
and they did them in school so it's not
a big deal but an outline is really the
main
work of screenwriting and it can take
twice as long as writing the script
itself if you've got a good outline you
can write a script and it will go pretty
quickly
figuring out all the possible
shapes and choices of an outline that's
brutally hard
so the answer is i would never take on a
job that i hadn't at least roughly
outlined because i wouldn't know that i
could solve it
um
do people ask you to do outlines for
free yes
should you do it for free no
it depends on where you are in your
career and what it's worth to you if you
want the experience of doing the outline
and you want to gain their trust but
don't do something you're going to
regret for free
i think that would be my advice on that
um
the other thing is um features
and shows are very different in shows
the outline breaking the story is a
required step for the company
it's also usually not done alone you
don't usually send one person off to do
it although sometimes you do
depends on the showrunner
but
outlining a show
is part of the
literally part of the job like you go
into the room you start by breaking the
story
so um
nobody would ask you to do that without
being paid because you're already on the
job
do you have a proven style of outlining
that has worked for you the most it's
proven to me
in the sense that yeah i think it's
great i've done a if you check out my
videos there's one called why outline
and one called how to outline the how-to
has the outline system
but basically what it really comes down
to is the important thing is to think in
scenes and write a
a written version where you are
writing down the scenes in a list that's
what an outline is an outline is a list
of scenes
some people can do it on index cards
they even have index card software where
you can put a lot on it
i believe that the important thing is to
understand
that you are breaking a story into
scenes and then when you have your full
list of scenes and you know what
everything is going to happen in every
scene and there's nothing missing
then you're ready to write so that's the
importance of an outline the actual form
of it
it's whatever works for you
i believe that the most important thing
the thing to put in that first line the
the the headline of each outline step
is not where it takes place or even what
happens it's what is the essential
action the point of the scene so the
point of this like we were talking
before about a scene where maya gets
fired
the point of that scene is that maya
gets unfairly fired
um you try to
make things active
always try to put things in active form
so maya gets fired is actually passive
she's getting fired the scene actually
is tommy fires maya unfairly now for me
that's a scene line because i know
exactly what the action is and i try to
always break it down to that sometimes
you know i'm the only one looking at it
oh that's the other thing outlines
should be for you
outlines are not to be read by other
people it's a workspace it's a workplace
if you have to do an outline for another
person that's a performance you should
copy your outline and then write a
version for other people to read but but
for you to work in an outline the
important thing is that you're doing
whatever will trigger you to understand
the point of the scene sometimes i know
a scene so well that i'll just write joe
drives to dallas now i know that during
the course of that he has to have a
breakdown but doesn't matter i know what
that means but really the scene is joe
has a breakdown while driving to dallas
the important thing is the central
action of the scene
and while there may be many steps in any
scene
there's usually one thing more than
anything else that that scene is about
and that's the point of the outline
then for me underneath it i'll put
everything i can think of i'll write
dialogue in my outline i'll do whatever
i can because i can always just cut and
paste it out later but that space under
the headline is where you can ask
yourself questions
you can and i write them in a different
color i write
why is joe having a breakdown how do we
know that joe is having a breakdown and
then i'll answer it
and i'll describe maybe i'll say like he
crumples up his hamburger and smashes it
into the rear view mirror whatever it is
i'm trying to get everything i can into
the outline so that i will know what it
is when i write the scene
those outline descriptions can be very
long they can be arguments with myself
the most important thing to do though is
break everything into a scene there's
nothing that is going to go into your
script that isn't in a scene so the
whole point of an outline is to get you
to remember if i don't have a scene
where that happens if i don't have a
scene where that subject is raised or
that feeling occurs
it's not going to be in the story
how common is it for you to write
backwards
i
always believe everyone should write
backwards but by that i do not mean you
actually start in the last scene and
write it right backwards i mean
know the ending that's really what right
backwards means
right backwards is a crucial thing
because until you know the ending you
don't actually know what your story is
about for instance
if
if you're telling a story in which
someone is trying to save their sister
from
lions
then
whether or not they actually do save
their sister and how they do it do they
do it by overcoming their fear of lions
or do they do it by learning lion
language and telling the lions to stop
that's going to be what the story is
about until you know that last thing the
thing that resolves the tension you
don't really know how to write anything
else so
work backwards really means
know your ending once you know the
ending
everything else makes sense in a
different way because you know that it's
an obstacle towards that or a step
towards that
when you were asked to take out that
core part of the one script
um did you go back to your outline and
you saw it there i don't know if it was
like the midpoint or where it was
and then try to reiterate like how did
when you went to that what was your
reaction to seeing that actually
i i totally failed on the first time i
had to do this so i'll tell you about
the second time when i succeeded at it
but the important thing is if you're
taking out the core of a story if you're
talking about the essential center of
the story it's not going to be in one
place the horrible thing the reason that
you can't do it is because it's in every
scene and that every single action the
person's taking is about a thing and if
they say let's not do that thing
then you're
really in trouble because you have to
rewrite everything
and worse than rewrite everything you
don't have any reason to do the other
thing
so you don't just tear it out you have
to replace it
i was working on a thriller it was about
a schizophrenic woman
living in new york she had just been
released from a mental hospital and
she's living in a crappy poor apartment
in hell's kitchen and the woman next
door to her is having an affair with a
police officer a street cop
and the
they have an argument the lovers have an
argument and during the argument
they the woman grabs the cops gun it
goes off
while he's trying to get it back and he
kills her
the schizophrenic woman hears all this
through the wall
and tries to leave
and when she does the cop sees her and
the rest of the thriller is
what's going to happen about that
i was in a very ornate 1970s
character-based kind of frame of mind so
not only did i add that but i added two
more characters one was an evil sergeant
who was trying to force the cop who was
actually
not a bad guy
to kill the witness
so the villain is actually
the murderer's boss
the woman who has the witness
has nowhere to go no no one's gonna
listen to her she's schizophrenic she
says she heard something to the wall
what you know
um
so the one person that she had to turn
to in my first draft of the story was a
guy who wasn't orderly
in the hospital where she was
and he was very kind to her
and she finds him and she tells him what
happened she asked for his help
that was a very ornate
complex set of relationships
and
jody foster's company
loved it but it was difficult and they
god bless them they gave me a lot of
money and a lot of time and they worked
with me and we worked on it
trying to figure out how to make it a
little more acceptable to the studio
system
and the executive there was meglifoe who
is now a phenomenal teacher and writer
um
and
we worked on it and she never asked the
thing that
i knew we needed
but she never said could we cut one of
these four characters
you've got a thriller with four main
characters
and i eventually said i think there's a
way to get rid of the guy that the
mentally ill person goes to now that
was taking out the core of the story
because by the end of the story they
have teamed up to defeat the evil
sergeant
and so i was removing the center of the
story
and
i had been asked before in other jobs to
remove the center of the story and it
just ruined my life so in this case i
thought you know
i asked the essential question what is
this story about and the story was about
this woman who
knew that she had heard a real thing but
because of her disability people were
not taking her seriously and the people
who
were taking her seriously were trying to
kill her right
she's the center of the story
and i had divided her action among two
people i thought that was cool as a
writing exercise it is cool as a movie
for jody foster it's not cool it was a
dumb choice but on the other hand when i
wrote it jody foster wasn't going to do
it so um once i moved into that position
i thought you know what this
woman's character needs to hold the
whole story on herself and the
relationship really is about her and the
poor policemen in between her and the
villain
so from a four-way story i made it a
three-way story
it was better it was a better version
now i had worked really hard on the
four-way version and i loved it
and i was very proud of myself for
recognizing
that there are even with something that
is
like i think it's great the original
version but it's not the only way to do
it and that was a real breakthrough for
me to recognize that something that i
loved and felt right
also had another version that i loved
and eventually felt was even more right
the triangle version was much more
powerful and the characters became much
more interesting
so
how do you do it you look at what is the
real center of the story the center of
the story was this woman that because of
her disability had
very limited ability to defend herself
or get help
and how she found the resources of
communicating with people
to solve that problem
did the film ever get made with another
last no it didn't and they tried they
tried so hard they were wonderful um
they they did but it was just a really
hard project at a really
hard time and there's a lot of times
when something you don't get all the
pieces together and if you follow the
trades you'll often see this happening
where
a passion project for someone
but it requires
to get
the right alignment of stars and
financing and all these other things
have to come together and everyone has
to believe in it for all their own
reasons
it's a frankly a astonishing that
anything gets made at all
i would watch that movie me too yeah
yeah that's well it's it's powerful
but um but the answer is how do you
remove the center of your story and the
answer is
you look for where it is in the story
and you'll usually find
it's it's not where you're the thing
you're clinging to
because the thing you're clinging to is
clearly making people uncomfortable and
if enough people are telling you
something is not working for them
you have to come to a choosing point you
have to say
i want it to work for me and i don't
care about anybody else
but if an if a lot of people are saying
i really love this but it's not working
in this way you have to think about is
there something about that that you can
rethink
the other thing is sometimes you have to
remove the heart of your story and then
you better just replace it find a new
heart find a new core to the story that
works well
and the story will keep living
wow that was like so metaphorically
well-turned yeah
with with this story was was the
schizophrenic woman was it her journey
out of
um the hospital into quote normalized
life or was it also getting people to
regard her as that was actually one of
the big problems was it was very
important to me
to fairly portray
what often is not shown in movies most
movies are like well if they could just
get sympathy they'd be cured
and the reality of her illness was that
she was not going to get all over it
with an insight she had a serious mental
illness and the question was how can she
communicate and gain others trust and
learn to trust them in order to get help
and so one of the hardest things was
essentially a lot of people wanted it to
become
a story about someone who's a
neglected action hero
and and that's not what what the company
wanted you know they really respected
the point of the script and certainly
not what i intended i wanted to try and
talk about what it's like
to have a mental illness and need to
work
with it
you